mostly the chief of the watchdog body
had nothing but praise
for the police in what he said have been
a very difficult year they've been
exemplary
in policing the pandemic particularly he
said in the face of mixed messages
from ministers standing behind podiums
he was talking about the confusion that
the public and
the police had felt over what was a law
and what was advice but he was quite
strong
on this um this question of vetting he
said that there needed
to be much more care in choosing
recruits and then monitoring
the potential corrupt officers uh in
every force
i mean all this of course in the wake of
the sarah everard case
um pc wayne cousins the metropolitan
police officer who had admitted recently
kidnapping raping and murdering sarah
everard
um he had been suspected of previous
attacks but he hadn't been
properly investigated or
vetted so should never really have
joined the met
so tom winter had this to say
organized crime gangs will try to
infiltrate the police
with young men and women who have no
criminal history
no criminal record they're not known to
the police
enter the police and get into positions
where they have access
to witnesses to evidence to
opportunities to frustrate criminal
investigations
the chief inspector also went on to a
number of other matters
including encouraging the government to
get
tough on the bosses of social media
sites
for publishing what he described as
unimaginable material on
child sex violence and and terror
matters
he said it wasn't simply enough to find
the companies and you couldn't put
companies in court he said but you could
put ceos in court and he urged the
government to
use a new uh a new act that's coming up
um to give police powers
to get those chief officers into court
and threaten them if they could prove
willful
negligence to threaten them with going
to jail